the envelopes please mr holden
may we hear the sound of the envelope
tearing
uh you open it doors all right
the winner is and the winner is
and the oscar goes to the oscar goes too
and the oscar goes to
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning and welcome to nominations
for the 90th academy awards i'm john
bailey governor of the cinematographers
branch
and president of the motion picture
academy
this has been a remarkable year for the
movies
actors writers producers and directors
have given us films that not only
entertain
but challenge us there's been bold
adventurous work in
animation documentaries and foreign
language films
visual effects composers and sound
artists
production designers editors and
cinematographers
continue to raise the bar of their
crafts
as do costumers make up and hair artists
this is a landmark year to honor their
achievements
now please join me in welcoming our
hosts
the irreverent star of girls trip
tiffany haddish and caesar from planet
of the apes actor director
andy circus
hey good morning it's an honor for us to
be here for the announcement of the
nominees
of the 90th oscars we're just seconds
away from the first announcement
as part of this event we're going to be
showing you a few short videos to
introduce some of the categories
like this one right here
[Music]
here are the nominees for achievement in
production design
beauty and the beast blade runner 2049
darkest hour dunkirk
and the shape of water
do you think they can install a steam
shower in my house because they look
like i need one
now it's time for our second category
[Music]
for achievement in cinematography
blade runner 2049
darkest hour dunkirk
mudbound and the shape of water
next are the creative geniuses who
ensure that we actors dress the part
and are never naked on screen
[Music]
for achievement in costume design
beauty and the beast darkest hour
phantom thread the shape of water
and victoria and abdul
now let's see our nominees in the next
two categories
[Music]
[Applause]
here are the nominees for achievement in
sound editing
baby driver blade runner 2049
dunkirk the shape of water
and star wars the last jedi
and for achievement in sound mixing
baby driver blade runner 2049
dunkirk the shape of water
and star wars the last jedi
i got to see this dunkirk it seems like
a lot of people like it yeah
but star wars the last jedi i could do
with a bit of a hand as well i know yeah
we got to watch both of those let's keep
up the pace next video please
[Music]
for best animated short film
deer basketball garden party
lou negative space
and revolting rhymes
and now here are the nominees for best
live action
short film dekalb elementary
the 11 o'clock my nephew
emmett the silent child
and watu water all of us
[Applause]
the last category proves that length
doesn't matter
and now it's time for our next category
[Music]
for original score
dunkirk phantom thread
the shape of water star wars the last
jedi
and three billboards outside ebbing
missouri
[Applause]
and now the next category
[Music]
for achievement in visual effects
blade runner 2049
guardians of the galaxy vol 2
kong skull island star wars the last
jedi
and war for the planet of the apes
without the master of their craft
without the masters of their crafting
this category
the average movie would be like 18 hours
[Music]
long
[Applause]
[Music]
for achievement in film editing
baby driver dunkirk
i tonya the shape of water
and three billboards outside ebbing
missouri
and now the final category in the first
half of this morning's announcements
[Music]
[Applause]
for achievement in makeup and hair
styling
darkest hour victoria and abdul
and wonder
we still have more nominee announcements
but we'll be we'll be back in a moment
a one minute and a half break do we get
to take a nap yeah
oh cool
and we won't stop
oh
oh
so
whatever
whatever
uh
oh
and we won't stop
what a great morning here we are the
nominees for performance by an actress
in a supporting role
mary j blige and mudbane
allison janney in i tonya
leslie manville in phantom thread
laurie metcalf in ladybird
and octavia spencer in the shape of
water
[Music]
for performance by an actor in a
supporting role
willem dafoe in the florida project
woody harrelson in three billboards
outside edmond
ebbing missouri yeah
richard jenkins in the shape of water
christopher plummer in all the money in
the world
and sam rockwell in three billboards
outside ebony missouri
[Applause]
for best foreign language film
a fantastic woman chile
the insult lebanon
loveless russia
on body and soul hungary
and the square sweden
[Applause]
for best documentary short subject
edith and eddie
heaven is a traffic jam on the 405.
heroin
knife skills
and traffic stop
all these titles make a woman from an
urban area very uncomfortable
i'm just saying no i'm totally up here
for best documentary feature
abacus small enough to jail
faces places
icarus
last men in aleppo
and strong island
[Applause]
for original song
mighty river from mudbound
mystery of love from call me by your
name
remember me from coco
stand up for something for marshall
and this is me from the greatest showman
for best animated feature film
the boss baby
the breadwinner
coco
[Applause]
ferdinand
and loving vincent
[Applause]
here are the nominees for adaptation
screenplay
call me by your name james ivory
the disaster artist scott new standard
standard and michael h wilbur
[Applause]
[Laughter]
logan scott frank and james mangold
and michael green
molly's game aaron sorkin
and mud bound virgil williams and d
reese
[Applause]
for original screenplay the big sick
emily v gordon and kumail nanjiani
get out jordan peele
ladybird greta gerwig
the shape of water guillermo del toro
and vanessa taylor
and three billboards outside ebbing
missouri martin mcdonough
for performance by an actor in a leading
role
timothy chalamet and call me by your
name
daniel day lewis in phantom thread
daniel cool yeah
[Applause]
you know it he know his name and get out
gary oldman in darkest hour
and denzel washington in roman j israel
esquire
and for performance by an actress in a
leading role
sally hawkins in the shape of water
francis mcdormand in three billboards
outside ebby missouri
margot robbie in itanier
sasha ronan in ladybird
and meryl streep in the post
[Music]
[Applause]
here are the nominees for achievement in
directing
dunkirk christopher nolan
get out jordan peel
lady granite girl
phantom thread paul thomas anderson
and the shape of water guillermo de toro
you want to do the big one for the big
for the best picture
well i think we should both do it i mean
what could possibly go wrong
you don't know me that way you don't
know me at all and finally
here are the nine final here are the
nine films selected
as best picture nominees
call me by your name peter spears
luca niro
and luca
guadagnino emilia george
and marco mora bento
darkest hour tim bevin eric felner lisa
bruce
anthony mccarten and douglas urbanski
producers
dunkirk emma thomas and christopher
nolan producers
get out sean mckittrick jason blum
edward h ham jr and
jordan peel producers
ladybird scott rudin eli bush
and evelyn o'neil producers
phantom thread joanne seller paul thomas
anderson megan ellison
and daniel loopy producers
the post amy piskell
steven spielberg and mccosko
couric producers
freedom
the shape of water guillermo del toro
and
j miles dale produces
[Applause]
and three billboards outside evan
missouri
graham broadbent peter
zernan and martin mcdonough
producers
thank you very much everyone for
watching this morning and
congratulations to all the nominees and
make sure you watch as we celebrate the
90th oscars
sunday night march 4th on abc
thank you